counterstrike is 15 years old this
staple of multiplayer gaming showed up
on fileplanet or however the [ __ ]
download [ __ ] back in the day as a
humble mod for half-life and its
influence was instantly felt and his
still felt today counter-strike maybe 15
but unlike an angst-ridden teenager it's
still really enjoyable here are 15
reasons counter-strike is still cool the
maps these multiplayer arenas are battle
tested in a way nothing in video games
really has been it's humbling to think
we've been playing these classics for 15
years some of an updated in csgo with
new routes and nooks to dodge gunfire
and stuff versus cool community maps
specifically in csgo valve has held
contest to dig up and pack together the
best community made counter striking
maps and they have even made sure that
the creators are getting paid for these
packs and through Steam Workshop there
are so many custom maps to try you're a
cable breakdown which is you know
because they last long time ago took lot
and speaking of community still plenty
of players a massive number of people
are still playing all flavors of cs and
there are plenty of resources available
for new players to learn this story
games ins and outs and valve is also
concocting ways of keeping people
interested with an inventory system and
crate drops and stuff like dota 2 well
microtransactions really aren't that
cool backing up it's worth taking the
time to learn from these community
resources because it's competitive csgo
is built for hardcore competitive
players especially if you've got enough
friends to fill out a team but if you
just want to jump on and not have to
worry about purchasing a kevlar helmet
every round well it has casual mode the
matchmaking will get you counter
striking against each other in no time
just don't be the last one alive
otherwise you might get into some nice
fight counter-strike has this
entertaining propensity to just end up
in hilarious knife fights from time
Steyn hostage rescuing if the e3 showing
of Rainbow six siege has you excited for
rescuing some hostages well get those
office hostages out of the office safely
works on mac so you can play it at the
office works on low end PC
so you can play it at the office
headshots oh the gun selection even
though the majority of players are only
ever going to use em fours aks and
desert eagles the variety of guns is
great and they all have their own
characteristics the odd sick auto shotty
auto snipers and the scout they all have
this instant recognition and will evoke
memories of how you approach around when
you're equipped with each just by the
utterance of their names the off the
report the frustration the sworn oath
never to use it until you get so fed up
of being one shotted that you blow all
of your money on the next round an exact
your revenge always something to learn
whether it's insane grenade tossing
skills or tricky places to hide no
matter how much you place yes it seems
like you will never run out of things to
learn it's 15 freaking years old it's a
staple of gaming and that itself is
pretty freaky I need one more reason I
pitched this as 15 reasons for its 15th
birthday so I come in even one last one
so I could play it at the office I'm
working it's research here's the 15 more
years of counter-strike for an in-depth
history of this game be sure to check
out Daniel Dwyers escape from mount
stupid on the subject it's brutal and
also because nobody talks about
condition zero condition zero was a
boxed version of cs released in march
2004 entirely come on oh yeah